bonjour bonjour et bienvenue sur
diagonale tv pour la suite de ce
championnat du monde d'échecs quatrième
partie donc car yakine pièce blanche
face à magnus
car c'est le tenant du titre pièce noire
donc on va voir ce que a prévu
maintenant car yakine pour continuer le
débat
eh bien il revient tout de suite voilà à
son coût de 4 donc au niveau ripaille il
joue la variante avec le pion que va
faire car c'est ce qui va suivre la
partie précédente aux cinq claviers f3
cabaye et ses 600 corps et bien il
semblerait qu'on ait pour l'instant dans
ce championnat du monde un débat débat
sur sur la grande bleue rue lopez entre
les deux prétendants au titre le tenant
et son challenger donc cerqual kayak il
kbc 6 donc maintenant sator info b5
c'est le cas voilà affublé 5 on est dans
la rue lopez et maintenant que va
choisir
carstens qui va continuer comme il avait
joué la grande variante avec à 6 la
fameuse dont richard 10 entre la vache
ou est-ce qu'il va jouer cavalier m6
pour rentrer de lui aussi dans une
défense de berlin eh bien on va voir ça
tout de suite à six voilà il ne varie
pas x 4 cavaliers six cas maintenant
attention le point 4 étant prises ont
fait le rock on n'a pas peur de la prise
immédiate puisque on va jouer pour eux
maintenant donc à deux reprises voire
même on peut jouer un des cas tout de
suite ce qu'on quatre prisons ou to run
qui cloue le cavalier et on récupère le
matériel sans grosse avance difficulté
donc ici fawcett tout voilà ça y est
maintenant défend puisque maintenant
dans lequel prend 1,4 c'était un peu
plus embêtant puisque d'après fawcett
évidemment on est prêt à roque et on a
plus de vis-à-vis du roi donc les noirs
ne peuvent pas perdre de temps et
peuvent envisager les prendre avec
meilleure situation sans doute et la
becel moi le foot au bon moment dessin
couche à ce que fout ou et 3 petit rock
leur attention ici dans cette situation
là si les blancs jouent ces trois et on
peut avoir le fameux gambie marshall des
500 me marchal qui donc a été ressuscité
dernièrement dans le fameux la fameuse
réédition de pascal gaulle et de
capablanca du livre de casablanca 1900
blain pour la première fois traduit en
français et ou capable en cas explique
ce derby mais on va pas voir ça on va
voir la même que la partie précédente
puisque après h3b cette quasi la même
enfin les mêmes idées en tout cas des
trois voies la d3 les blancs décide de
ne pas jouer eux mêmes pour des cas donc
il ya passé trois et après les mêmes
coûts des six ici voilà des six qui
protège le pion ça libère maintenant le
câble et c6 qui protégeait parce que
cavaye extrême elle sait prendre et on
aimerait bien les cris des blancs elle
est noire pardon jouer car il ya cinq
pour éliminer ce fou qui est superbe
c'est toujours à la pièce une pièce
excellente pour les blancs se fout de
cases blanches il faut faut pas
l'échanger contre contre ce cavalier
donc les blancs voient la joue à trois
voilà c'est la même idée que
précédemment pour servir car yakine
cette espèce d'espagnol rampante là qui
que carson avait réussi à annuler son
trop difficultés alors pourquoi
revient-il là dessus et ce qu'il a prévu
quelque chose tu aimes 17 carsen suis un
développement extrêmement naturelle on
lui et tour en mettant la dame sur la
seule case où elle peut aller pour
permettre de lier les tours il n'y a pas
d'autre donc c'est facile à trouver
comme coûts et la qualité des deux voilà
on trouve des idées similaires aussi des
deux ans ce cavalier ensuite pourra
venir en f1 puis pourquoi pas j'ai trois
parfois h2 ou l'autre cavani 20 h deux
on va voir ça
ça c'est connu donc je passe pas trop de
temps la tour 8
voilà on continue le développement on
met cette tour en huit parce qu'on
n'envisage pas de jouer 5 puisque
évidemment il ya le fou qui veillent ici
donc c'est hors de question donc en
jouant tours 8
on laisse pas cette tour à la maison où
elle ferait rien on va jouer ensuite
c'est très certainement fouet fuite et
donc à tour aura une action directe sur
le sur le centre alors on note ici qu'on
n'a pas vraiment peur du coup comme
câblée g5 qui attaqueraient vii avec le
fou parce qu'ils ont su si suffirait de
jouer soit cahier des 8 soit parfois
même on joue tout à fait carrément
revient c'est pas grave puisqu'on va
chasser le cavalier par axis et puis au
final en remettra la tour 1,8 chacun
perdu alta ça change rien
ces trois a alors là cela c'est une
variation d'idées par rapport à ce qu'on
avait vu puisque maintenant c'est quand
même ces 3 jouez donc les blancs en
calcul et saigne peuvent maintenant
choisir soit de garder le fou sur la
grande diagonale ici on a 2 soit de le
mettre en c2 qui est aussi la position
standard dans dans la rue lopez puisque
après quand les blancs jour en plus
tarder car le jeu s'ouvre à bien ce fou
pourrait viser h7
voilà donc ça lui il avait des
possibilités choisira le moment venu
pour l'instant il est bien embêté roi la
foulée fluide pour les noirs voilà c'est
l'idée on a libéré l'action de la tour
des menaces auxquelles j'ai c'est qu'on
peut même jouer tours 700 en rapatrier
un cavalier loi dans son camp on joue
torres est simplement ça protège on est
prêt à mener sur a donné de la tour
contre deux pièces sur cas de sacrifices
ça serait pas bon pour les pour les
blancs et après tour sept ans plus on
pourrait ramener le tour en huit bon je
sais pas si je pense pas que ce soit
très bon de mettre une tout comme ça
derrière nous étions bloqués mais en
tout cas un les tours et en ligne et ça
devient facile de savoir quoi faire
cavaillé fin normale car il y fait bon
et on libère à l'action du fou ce
cavalier de toute façon comme on a joué
ses trois îles afin dé veloppement
rampante qui est traditionnel et sans
doute en g3 sa meilleure case très
certainement h 6
six maintenant il n'y a plus jamais de
cavalli g5 là donc ça s'est réglé qui
joue bien en plus on se ménage une
petite fenêtre pour moi c'est très
positionnelle notez bien d'ailleurs on
est sur ce coup là au 13e coup ça va
être le 14e des blancs regardez
l'échiquier on a joué beaucoup de coups
il faut remarquer quelque chose c'est
qu'il ya eu aucun échange tous les pions
sont là toutes les pièces sont là donc
c'est quand même une ouverture complexe
toute la complexité du jeu ici encore
maximale après quatorze coups aucun
échange cavaliers h2e le câble et qui
est sur la troisième rangée 20 h 2 voilà
c'est un peu ce qu'on avait vu aussi la
partie précédente de kayak in avec les
blancs cette idée qu'on avait signalé
équipe qui souvent thématiques aussi
dans l'espagnol un des deux cavaliers
alors celui là ou l'autre ça dépend des
fois celui là il va souvent j'ai 3 mai
sur celui-là voilà on veut venir au g4
angers 4 le plus tard ça permettra ça
fait pression sur h6 sur m6 et
entreprises mais on peut ramener un pion
vers le centre ça ouvre la colonne haché
et mine de rien mais on peut envisager à
moyen long terme d'attaqué le roi sur
cette colonne et puis le plonger peu
aussi servi de bélier pour les objets
simples ça forcerait les noirs à
s'affaiblir en janvier scène bref voilà
c'est une idée de position de cavaliers
tout à fait pertinente et voilà les blé
noir réagissent carsen réagit maintenant
au centre profite en fait du retrait des
pièces développement rappelant le
cavalier qui s'en va un petit peu du
centre qui profite de ce retrait pour
dire les blancs prépare quelque chose à
l'ale bombay c'est vrai que c'est assez
souvent considéré qu'une bonne réaction
de réagir au centre et c'est d'ouvrir le
jeu simplifié peut-être changer d'armes
entre un final et éliminer toute
tentative de d'attac d'accumulation de
forces pour monter une attaque on est en
question d'éliminer un maximum de pièces
voilà donc carrier qu'il évite quand
j'en avais trois en cas de prise en 4
n'a pas des changes de dames
vous gardez les dames donc ça veut bien
dire que les blancs jouent pour une
attaque contre le roi ski standard ça
nous rappelle les grandes parties
kasparov et karpov
il ya notamment une dont je me rappelle
à lyon 1990 qui était absolument
fabuleux je vous invite à aller la
découvrir une espagnole de kasparov qui
fait un match superbe dans une partie
d'anthologie face à face et carpeaux
qu'avaya cinq attaques donc ce fameux
fou b3 ils choisissent maintenant à deux
où ces deux ba2 voilà reste quand même
en a deux pour l'instant ce cas elle ne
peut pas venir au centre en ces cas
puisque itunes détroit qui veille mais
on prend voilà apprise prise donc ça y
est les noirs à l'escalier pour en venir
à ces quatre là l'intérêt de ce type de
coup c'est pas tellement bon c'est bien
ceux ci s'attaque un petit peu b2 bon
c'est pas un problème pour les blancs de
protéger ça on pourra le chasser plus
tard mission de chasse en bloc ce fou et
ont convenu en c4 surtout voilà on
bloque l'action de ce fou à 2 sur l'euro
g8 un peu pour boucher les diagonales et
faire taire un peu les pièces puissante
en replaçant ces pièces et en ayant
bougé car et en plus on a libéré la
force bien sûr du fou bessette sur le
curé 4 a donc ça il mobilise c'est là
aussi un peu les blancs en optimiser au
maximum la force de ces pièces ont émis
sur les meilleurs case là on exerce un
maximum de pression sur sur le camp
ennemi calais s'éclate rôle en bouche en
bouche l'action du fou et la voilà qui
coup il s il a laissé faire ici c'était
un peu l'idée de carsen avant ce coup
ils laissent faire ce superbe sacrifices
c'est quand même c'est joli évidemment
fou praxis si les noirs prennent racine
on perd le cavalier et le renoir se
retrouve affaibli
bon ceci dit on prend ainsi sont allés
chez honda hsv 2 donc qu'est ce qui se
passe si on prend tout de suite en b2
imaginons qu ici on essaie de se venger
sur le sur le plan b 2 on va voir mais
sur dit elle car son équipe à celle là
voilà ce cas là on pourrait simplement
jouer au cou comme fou gsm tout
simplement pour éviter la reprise
ce câble étant prises il faut le
protéger ou l'enlever ont pour ajouter
un lhc est aussi pour pas perdre de
temps attaquer le fou et ma foi mais ça
a l'air tout à fait jouable mais qu
arsène va tenter autre chose après tout
prend ainsi s'il a une autre idée l'a
laissé faire exprès pour jouer c'est pas
mal aussi bien sûr peut-être mieux
dams et six en mettant un maximum de
pression sur le puits en 4 à noter aussi
que en cas de cavaliers prendre quatre
eh bien le fois ci serait vraiment
emprise à noter qu'il est tout de suite
en prise puisque en plus en jouant ses 6
on protège le cavalier en fait on menace
non seulement le pied en cap mais aussi
en menacent maintenant de prendre six
avec le gain d'une pièce de manière
assez claire donc ici les blancs vont
faire les échanges pour simplifier cette
position donc il en profite pour prendre
ces quatre maintenant si la dame prend
c4 est bien dans ce cas là elle ne
protège plus le cavalier f6 et les
blancs auraient le temps de protéger eux
quatre donc en fait ils vont être
obligés pour garder la pression de
prendre du plomb mais voilà alors ça a
des avantages et des inconvénients
on met sur sa double les pions donc en
cas de transposition dans une finale
technique il est possible que les noirs
et des problèmes si ses pions saute ceci
dit c'est un peu ambigu puisque le pion
c4 aussi ici dominé tous ses pions là
ils peuvent pas bouger de c3 est bloqué
par poussées 4 et le pion b2 ne peut pas
avancer
puisqu'ils seraient pris en b3 donc à la
colonne baies ouvertes ici qui permet
aussi de faire pression sur b2
et qui donc dos noir des compensations
contre cette structure de pions
évidemment pas très très bonne donc là
mais n'en fallait enlever le fond là
c'est fait ils étaient attaqués et donc
carsen prend le pion aux quatre là donc
en fait il a fait une bonne affaire car
celle ci envers la position de suite
pourquoi parceque il a échangé en fait
ce puisse être contre se fiant aux
cadres le pion à cette île quand même
moins important que le pion aux 4 c'est
un pion central parce qu'après quand on
va bouger les pions ou même quand on va
consolider simplement le quiou 5 sél et
noir qui quand même plus de pression sur
le centre se puis on s'inquiète au
centre contrôle des 4es avec m6 on
protégerait e5 donc on a bonne position
au centre avec les pièces de cases
blanches ici ces deux pièces contrôle
sub très très bien aussi les cas
secondes donc la supériorité noir au
centre et maintenant net grâce à cet
échange finale après ses manoeuvres
ce quasi échanges en fait entre eux
achètent et aux quatre ça c'est un
premier point est le deuxième point
c'est qu'on l'a vu ce pion qui a repris
ici à casser la structure noir donc en
plus de ce côté là on peut se dire bon
ils ont dans un premier temps que carsen
bon en échange il a donné une structure
de pions mauvaise du côté dames mais on
l'a vu ce pion c4 immobilise les pions
on peut masse et des pièces peut-être
sur la colonne mais pour attaquer b2
donc on maintient quand même ce cette
zone sous pression ce qui fait que les
blancs peuvent pas profiter de cette de
ce désavantage voire même c'est eux qui
vont subir une pression ici donc
pression au centre pression sur cette
aile évidemment les blancs attentions
sont pas sans ressources ils ont une
structure de pions très saine aussi donc
en cas d'élimination du thon ckac
notamment ben et tout va se libérer et
peut-être que les blancs à ce cas là on
aurait pris un avantage sur le long
terme donc il faut faire attention ça
reste très tendue car les j3 de la part
des blancs a très bien sort
notre cave et g3 pourrait changer
ce taux est de 4 qui est un peu gênant
quand même bien placé au centre et refus
par carcelle simplement
il vient en d6 ce faisant il propose
donc les chances de dame avant 10 il est
bien aussi parce que regarder il protège
justement ces quatre et en plus il est
il est très très bien on est aussi parce
qu'il est protégé par le pion c7
ce cavalier donc il est pas vraiment
délogeables ce qui plus est si on
imagine avec le pion si c'est ici qu'on
les change un jour mais on rétablit avec
les noirs on pourrait rétablir la
structure de pions prenant s'éprend des
six on a rétabli une belle très belle
chaîne de pions ici et c'est les noirs
qui ont qui sont dominés au centre grâce
aux options adverse et qui en plus sont
dominées aussi sur neil dames avec cette
colombe et qu'il faut faire un faux très
prudent maintenant pour pour sergueï
kaliakine qui semble déjà un tout petit
peu sous pression avec très peu de
moyens bien il n'a pas on voit bien sûr
l'attaqué elle est pas là finalement
pour l'instant on ne voit pas on va pas
trop comment ce qu'il peut faire
peut-être les transposer en finale parce
que parce que finalement et ce en
attaque c'est peut-être sa chance de
rentrer dans une finale où peut-être sa
structure de pions meilleur pourra jouer
un rôle pour essayer d'inverser la
tendance
même si l'on met sur sa position reste
très saine et on peut pas dire qu'il ya
davantage en tout car les noirs s'en
sont très bien sortis d'un l'ouverture
torah d un très beau coup normalement
sur une pièce et maintenant voilà tour
avait 8
voilà ce que vous dites à l'heure on met
la tour l'abbé oui parce qu'on vise ceux
qui ont des deux colonnes semi ouverte
et andy celui ouverte puisque il ya le
pion au noir disparu mais pas le pion
blanc donc il y a que la moitié la
colonne qu'une verte
donc petite pression sur sur b2
évidemment fou c'est une fois qu'on a
joué autour des 1
c'est mieux de le faire a bien sûr une
fois qu'on a vu autour des 1 la tour est
active on ramène le foie la maison eut
pas plus mal ici que là puisque là en
plus il bloquer l'action de la tour e 1
sur le pion on défend b2c très difficile
pour les noirs maintenant dans cette
position d' envisager d'attaquer b2 avec
une seule main tour faudrait qu'une
autre pièce comme le cavaly viennent
attaquer mais c'est pas facile parce que
californie qui les disent y aura 4 et le
fou s'est il peut pas attaquer des deux
donc c'est un très bon coup de défense
tout en ayant une pièce qui a quand même
diagonale intéressante ici qui à tout
moment peut sortir sur pas mal de cases
donc c'est un très bon une très bonne
fête développement pour khanaqinne même
si c'est les noirs grâce à la majorité
centrale un petit pression sur colombes
et même sur ses cadres qui quand même et
pénible contre la casse des trois là les
noirs adorerait un maître une puissante
des trois là ça perturberait totalement
le gant blanc m6 protège surprotège donc
le seul qui ait une petite chaîne de
pions et on affaiblit pas centrale en
surprotège ce pion essentiel il est au
centre y contrôler la casse des quatre
ils bloquent la colonne eux ils peuvent
menacer de venir e4 plus tard à tout
moment belle chaîne de pions très
difficile pour les blondes d'envisager
une attaque ici un contre ça c'est très
très solide très très bon jeu
positionnelle de 400 c'est propre c'est
agréable à voir et c'est assez évident
et la dame prend ses six de série car à
qui on rendra la finale vous prend donc
là maintenant donc finale sont deux
dames et les faits il reste encore
beaucoup de plans il peut depuis ont
changé on est structurellement la
position des pions morales dame semble
délicate c'est un peu le cas mais
pression pour sa colombe est un pion c4
qui contrôle des trois ans le ska
détroit très importante ici et peut-être
que attention faut pas permettre à
l'adversaire mettre une pièce ici ça
peut être avant postes pour une tour
pour le cavalier pour un fou n'importe
quoi qui peut gêner puisque
les blancs serait alors extrêmement
refermer dans le camp dans leur camp on
le voit un truc extrêmement sous
pression avec une pièce on d'être donc
et blanc réagissent par cavalli g4
lecavalier qui arrange de ne faisait
rien heavy angers 4 et survit vise pas
maintenant ces cases la même si mission
qui contrôle de l'adversaire les
tiennent bien aussi mais il veut sans
doute revenir aux 3 et peut-être 2 3 il
vise c4 justement et on peut envisager
soit sacrifice de qualité pour prendre
ces quatre peut être éliminé ce cavalier
par l'autre cavalli qui viendra ainsi
cinq ou six en éliminer après on revient
et là c'est nous qui faisons pression
sur ce pion qui potentiellement aussi
pourrait s'avérer faible et pas facile à
attaquer comme on le voit une tour peut
pas venir l'attaqué va pas venir sur la
quatrième rangée non plus tout élu
protéger pas facile à attaquer ses pions
peut-être une fois mais il faudrait
attaquer plus d'une fois pour ça pose
problème
tombé 5 pour les pour les noirs ou
intéressant on active la tour peut-être
que les blancs veulent jouer tout v8
pourquoi pas envisager un sacrifice de
qualité en b2 à la fin puisque avec le
fouet fuite on pourrait en plus prendre
à trois et pourquoi pas il pour
attention parce que c'est le type de
pouilly de partis ou sacrifice de
qualité pour avoir davantage de pions
pour la dame ça peut jouer on fait
attention à ce que vont faire les les
noirs et les blancs de jouer un coup
intéressant f3 f3 et le il joue contre
ce fou ses pions la joue contre ce fou
et aussi j'ai un petit oeil sur la case
de quatre ans maintenant la poussée aux
4 contres et enfin pseudo contre en tout
cas part à la prise permettrait d
échanger peut-être que les blancs
veulent échanger à l'attention parce que
s'il ya beaucoup des changes
la structure en des pions noirs risque
s'avérer délicate mais carcelle pour
l'instant semble quand même avoir
l'avantagent dynamique est là qu arsène
passe aux choses sérieuses maintenant
que la banale tour et vous demandez en
bessin que non seulement je pouvais
envisager doublé faire des choses mais
aussi ici je contrôle
là le pion aux 5 donc ça veut dire que
j'ai deux défenseurs sur ce pion aux
cinq qui est à tacler que deux fois par
le cabinet à tour donc ça rend les
autres pions mobile même s'il a joué 26
pour bien protéger elle le fait de
protéger deux fois en scène par les
pièces maintenant permet de jouer bas la
suite alors les boums f5 voilà je chasse
des pièces foutrait faut bien réfléchir
ajoute quand on joue ça puisque la
tension le pion aux saignements pourrait
s'avérer une cible même s'ils ont enfin
bougé
il faut faire attention en planque
précieux car sensi câble et 2 et la
jolie coup fawcett
ils activent sada la pièce là qui pour
l'instant joué pas trop parce que c'est
cette pièce c'est magnifique quand même
le full à contrôler ou bien les cases
blanches soutiennent poussé aux quatre
ultérieure de la vallée des six est très
super bien placé aussi contrôler la
centrale contre le c4 elle que le fou et
filles qui jouaient pas fawcett
on veut peut être le maître en h4 au
moins on va pouvoir en fait une petite
pression en haïti où valcke a b g iii ou
alors on peut aussi le mettre en règle 6
tout simplement pour soutenir le pion
celle qu'on a remplacé le pur et f6 par
le fou qui est très bien aussi donc là
les blancs réagissent pour faire quelque
chose par f4 alors ça c'est un coup
intéressant un peu tendu qu'est ce qui
se serait passé
c'est parce qu'il sait a été joué qu'est
ce qui se serait passé sur pions pro f 4
qui a l'air très bon tout simplement
parce que l'un des pions là le même si
c'est un pion doublé basse et comme dit
l'autre un puritain pions en plus ce
pion f4 on va pouvoir le le protéger par
gsm que ça semble bon faut faire
attention ici qui est pas de choses et
ça va être tout à fait jouable
ça avait l'air tout à fait jouer des
blancs pourrait reprendre ici tout
simplement mais dans ce cas là il hd2
voilà une hache b2c pas un problème
vous prendrez en cas de prisons des six
sont rendus pions et pas de problème on
peut même prendre du fou d'ailleurs
puisque la tour 8 est protégé par le
faisait six ans prend b2 1 et les noirs
sont bien les noirs sont bien là
donc plus nette option doublet mais plus
en plus avec une structure blanche qui
est faible un avantage qui semble n'être
semblerait que la prise en main 4 était
bien on va même très bien mais il suit
un petit peu l'idée pose la deuxième
idée qu'on avait dit c'est qu'il vous
l'activez sont fous donc en fait il faut
h théâtre
bon c'est pas mal aussi mon mais parce
qu'ils activent le faut il donc il
rencontrera le sel qui peut menacer
pourquoi pas 2 au 4 de prendre f4
toujours bon mais là surtout il pose une
question aux cavaliers les blancs
répondent pas à la question tout de
suite ils prennent d'abord en 5,6 et
noir près le cavalier je me venge sur
l'autre rabon très bien passée ce qui
fait faux projet 3e prend des six voilà
alors la tour 8 et protéger ceux ci je
peux faire un échange intermédiaire
puisque tout reprend échec faut répondre
à l'échec et ensuite je reprends des six
c'est ce qui fait tout reprend pour
prendre et maintenant donc il reprend on
l'avait dit tout à l'heure en cas de
prise du cavalier on pouvait envisager
de regrouper les pions s'il prend du fou
il laisse les prix ont doublé
donc est ce qu'il fait à votre ami
évidemment il reprend du pian donc voilà
il a dédoublé les pions ce qui fait
croire des soupirs mais on peut avancer
on peut venir en dessin qu'on pourrait
venir en le préparant ensuite dans des
quatre essais changé et finalement on a
n'a pas de problème là il est un peu
arriérés ce pion mais bon ce pas trahi
protégé par le fou on peut même jouer le
fonds uff 5 peut-être des choses comme
ça on peut ramener l'euro vers le centre
bonne position toujours pour les noirs
et les blancs qui sont sous pression le
vont le voit le lien ils sont sur trois
rangées alors que ce sont les
adversaires qui a quand même eu plus
d'espacé ici qu'il ya pas plus avancé en
plus donc les noirs après ces échanges
ont la paire de fou
alors la paire de fou ça a maintenant ça
commence à peser aussi perdre fou dans
une position un peu éclairé comme ça
c'est un petit avantage donc avantage
noir avantage mort toujours rien décisif
encore bien sûr mais une bonne une bonne
finale pour pour les noirs car senard a
réussi avec ses pieds noirs donc à
rentrer en finale favorable c'est à
noter pour la suite du match ça fait
deux fois que carl et qu'il n'arrive pas
obtenir rien d'intéressant
c en est sorti on l'a vu dans une avec
une magnifique défense avec les noirs
sur sur les deux précédentes car yakine
mais avec les blancs il a du mal a du
mal à sortir avec un avantage donc tour
des petites pressions bon sur des six
est protégé par le fonds bref cette
série de coups maintenant parce qu'on va
entrer dans une longue finale on va pas
toutes analysées sinon ça serait trop
long tour des 4 tours 5 à noter ici à le
piège un tour prend des six il y aurait
tout échec à on bouge et même pas on est
mat
d'ailleurs il s'évade du couloir puisque
le roi ici voilà mais même s'ils avaient
pas mates tout reprendre tout rishek
imaginons qu'ils aient pas de matelas le
fou après pourrait prendre la tour qui a
deux idées donc troisième la smat roi f1
est quasiment forcé et la tour des cinq
pas mal tour des 5 alors qu'elle est
l'idée de tourner 5
imaginons que les blancs tu prennes en
c4 non c'est parce que c'est le coût
immédiat ce qui semble naturel le foot
attaquer c'est pas que la tour peut
venir là c'est que regarder ici
simplement up your est fou des cinq
plages
aïe aïe aïe adieu terminé on signe leur
insigne le point donc tour des scènes qu
on prose sait qu'arsène qui propose
échange du tour vous rentrez dans cette
finale perdre fou et oui mais bon il n'y
a pas de plus en plus donc voilà
l'activité s'est pas transformé en
points de plus mais un peu la paire de
fou c'est les noirs qui sont mieux
clairement tout reprend ses parents
voilà donc la longue file la technique
de fou contre x cavaliers foxy villeroy
il faut que les royaux plus possible au
centre si on peut il va falloir essayer
avec les pions de créer des ruptures un
petit peu pour pour créer des menaces de
pions passé faut créer des ponts passé
alors les blés noirs peuvent envisager
des actions passées on peut c'est ce
plan créé des menace d'affaiblissement
si les blancs ne prennent pas au passage
à lyon un pion passé et avec ses pions
là on peut essayer aussi de jouer
la f4 on peut essayer simplement cédé
des fous voilà donc foulé 5 pour les
blancs moi j'ai six attaques le fou on
amène aussi le roi un peu plus près dans
le camp ennemi par contre s'éloigne un
peu du centre ici il faut réagir quand
même avec les blancs ici h4 choisi à ce
cadre là c'est un peu délicat parce que
on peut envisager bien sûr maintenant de
faire 3 5 puisque et puis on s 4 certes
défend le full maintenant comment on
protège on peut pas cavalier peut pas
venir à la rescousse l'euro est trop
loin dans ce piège semble perdu dans ce
cas l'accord effet les corps effet les
blancs sans doute cavale et h3 et
maintenant si les noirs prennent tout de
suite en page 4 alors il aurait
peut-être en europe lui reprendre il
peut faire aussi cette manoeuvre échec
aura prend cavaliers prend ses 6 et
maintenant le problème c'est que les
noirs eux mêmes ne pourront pas défendre
ses quatre sûrs que le prochain coup de
blanc sera t elle et b6 énorme peuvent
enfin le roi peut pas venir la rose
côtoyer les bloqués ici par le cavalier
voilà donc on va reprendre ce pion et
alors là par contre c'est dangereux
parce que si ça ça saute
la structure des pions noirs et
mauvaises ces trois pions lier la les
blancs peuvent se conjuguer au passé
même si c'est calé contre tout ça peut
s'inverser un peu quoi mais le fou du
roi quand même tenir mais bon on
n'allait pas là puisque c'est quand même
à près de 4% séoul 1 de jouer cavalier
h3 et
les noirs jouent fouet f7 prennent pas
tout de suite donc anjou info f7 la
manoeuvre convient de voir ne marche
plus c'est à dire que maintenant si en
cas de prise ya pas cavalier chèque pour
prendre le fou de cases blanches donc ce
fou garde le contrôle de ces quatre et
en menace de gagner un pylône est il
blanc donc semble un petit peu embêté
c'est curieux ce couac hommes 24 ici est
trop série peut-être car iachini pour
faire autre chose hélas donc fouet cette
donc la contre attaque des six ça c'est
toujours en prise forcé mais on le
constatait sur décision promettre le fou
cédé 6 qui saute
bon ceci dit les noirs pourraient
pourrait tenter un coup comme comme des
saints qui sont comme ça je protège il
ya fait ses plus attaquer donc là
maintenant je me lasse de prendre que
font les blancs il semblerait que les
noirs gagné bouillon ceci dit attention
parce qu on échangerait sans doute ce
fou et se fout là est un fou qui est
quand même mauvais parce qu'il est sur
la couleur de ses pions et le cavaly
mobile pourrait quand même sans doute
aller se balader dans le camp ennemi par
f4e deux des quatre là et puis à
l'attaqué ce pion à la et le fonds
pourra pas défendre tout à la fois le
pion à le pion des et il est que
défensif de ce côté là voilà donc c'est
sans doute l'idée des blanches dans un
pion mais avec ce temps là je te laisse
un mauvais fou et ça ira donc car ça ne
rentre pas là dedans
après fawcett il fait pas des 5
mais ils finissent ils échangent des
fonds pour acheter être assez pas la
peine donc ils laissent le pion sur
cases noires ce qui fait que ça rend
plus fou que moi un peu moins mauvais
puisqu'il peut aller en des scènes
peintes allons donc dans les manoeuvres
de cavaliers c'est pas tout à fait la
même la même partie
en 17 ans fera pression sur g2 ça peut
aider
parce que là il ya un pion passer ça
peut aider à créer des menaces et à
mettre les blancs en difficulté a serré
le roi de ce côté là puis avec le lot en
irak et l'autre côté et c'est donc on va
enchaîner par fou prend des six et voilà
on revient on garde la paire de foule un
des mythes en 2g 5 ça y est on met en
mouvement
attention c'est pas un pion de plus ses
deux pions contrôle d'un côté trois
points contre 2 de l'autre mais vous
voyez toujours pareil ce pion domine ce
ce trio peut pas bouger en fait donc les
noirs on double avantage père de fou est
due aux mobiles de pions contre eur
alors que l'autre côté le bio de plus
des blancs ne joue pas donc ça n'aurait
que la position sur presque peut-être
même gagnante pour les noirs soit un jeu
précis mais bon attention il reste peu
de pions donc si on certifie la une
pièce contre le plan ce qui reste là par
contre de pièces contre unsa finul
cavaillé deux mois j'ai six voix revient
j'ai quatre quarts yakine propose des
échanges
il met son pion donc sur cases blanches
couleurs opposées à celles de son fou ça
lui fait pas peur
le foot les gens pourraient venir
attaquer mais qu'at elle les défend le
roi pourra défendre peut-être bon on
n'en est pas là si on nord de jouer
qu'est-ce qu'ils choisissent alors il ya
peine coup on peut prendre angers 4 mais
ça permettra d'activer le cavalier on
peut jouer f4 donc comme je disais mais
il estimait ce que c'est bon pour garder
un petit peu f4 ici la structure est
particulière g4 un tout petit peu faible
mais c'est pas facile d'aller attaquer
et que le fou qui peut l'attaquer et ce
qu'on voit pas le roi faire le tour là
c'est impossible donc le fouet si on
attaque il suffit de me touré en défense
donc ça craint rien en fait on peut même
se balader avec lecavalier s'est trouvé
des cases c'est pas forcément facile
mais on peut essayer et le roi restait
un peu moins dans le coin donc dès que
les noirs attaque le pion on joue en f3
tranquille mais elle est bien sûr en
défense
voilà s'avère qu'ils acceptent la de
répéter des coups sans doute de faire
nul donc gros succès dans cette partie
pour qu'arsène en terme de sorties
d'ouverture et milieu dieu la finale
quand même avantageuse nettement avec
les noirs faut 5
alors donc j'ai quatre fous b6 je
reviens donc là maintenant fossé voilà à
5 à 5 continue à mettre les pieds ici
sous pression et préfère mettre le pion
sur noir ici que le laisser sur blanc
bon pourquoi pas un jugement
positionnelle cavaliers contrefout fondé
tout calculer on va pas le faire trop de
coups là maintenant il faut quand même
qu'on on essaie d'arriver au bout sinon
ça serait trop long kavala d1
voilà on replace le cavalier on n'a pas
peur il est blanc laisse tomber ici le
projet 4 à noter un donc ici on le fout
quand même attaqué ce cavalier proposé
peut-être en échange on n'a pas peur de
lâcher le pion les blancs considère qu'
ils tiennent à kg troaré que bon ceci
passé pas très gênant pourquoi pas est
donc ici les noirs jouent f4 plutôt que
de prendre le pion vision bijoux f4
pions pas ses protégés avec la paire de
fou mais on joue encore serré avantage
noir net fou des 4 propose un échange
alors attention bien sûr ici est ce que
ça vaut le coup d'y échanger c'est pas
sûr ça va être difficile le noir encore
une fois de défendre ses deux pions avec
contre le cavalier en plus si on prend
créer un pion passé pour les blancs et
après calais c3 ce qu on pourrait
avancer ça pose des problèmes aux noirs
soit le roi va être occupée soit le fou
pendant ce temps là et blanc vont
pouvoir faire aller grappiller quelques
pions sans doute donc fou c'est 7
il refuse garde la paire de fou on est
deux fois six ailleurs natale j'ai 4 ans
et parlait tout à l'heure déjà wave 3
voilà quand j'ai quatre attaques et en
euro f3 à noter que ça veut dire quelles
propositions implicite de nul ici parce
que les noir et blanc peut jouer échec
et le roi n'a pas de casque de revenir
en deux ans revient aux six et si les
blancs rouges joueront avec 3 etc
voilà donc les blancs sont heureux
semble content avec la nuit ici ils ont
rien ils admettent avec ce coup qu'ils
en rien quelque sorte donc l'écart scène
fait quand même fou des cinq échecs roi
le 2 mai il répète pas parce que là il
sait bien qu il al avantage
on le voit au cou en fait voilà on le
voit au refus nul tout simplement même
si on comprend pas tout dans des parties
de champion c'est un truc que je vous
donne si vous suivez pas tout le type de
coup vie joué par les joueurs vous
permettent de savoir qui joue pour le
gain qui joue pour les nuls celui qui
accepte de répéter les coups bas et ça
veut dire qu'il est bien content de
faire mieux donc fou j'ai deux voies la
foulée 2 c'est bien un fou et angers 2
ça veut dire que si on joue f3 plus tard
le four est mieux placé que derrière le
pion puisqu'ils contrôlent la caisse de
promotion du pion ça joue pas tout de
suite mais bien placé quoi la pression
est maximale croit d2 et blanc accepte
de ils veulent essayer sans doute les
blancs de venir en c2 pour jouer b3
quittés bons ils vont casser leur
structure ici mais on se libérer un pion
passé on s'est cru un peu de contrôle de
l'autre côté peut-être
bref cette ce sont les noirs mais dans
qui activent leur pièce le roi tu as
besoin de se replacer pour être optimale
à noter que ce fonds g2 est magnifique
il n'empêche le cavalier de mire en
quatre et ans à 3 donc ya pas de
problème sur un sur m6 peut pas venir
attaquer f6 facilement 3 ces deux à
noter la lecavalier joue son rôle
puisqu'il n'ya pas d'échec on croise et
de on est bien placés sous des sacs
noirs revient l'un des scènes et donc
ils empêchent b3 donc c'est à dire que
carsen estime qu'il ne fallait pas
laisser les blancs justement se donner
de l'air de ce côté là en cas de b3
prises hors apprend on aurait pu venir
embêter aussi le pire c'est qu'on se
crée des pions passé bon bain les noirs
n'ont ici bien sûr mais pour progresser
c'est pas simple donc
on équilibre aurait le jeu parle
l'équilibré dynamique
on croit d2 pour les blancs pour un fer
peut pas passer si le foot en dessin
qu'on peut rien faire ou des huit
protection en 9,6 pourquoi parce qu'on
veut libérer le roi là on veut le faire
bouger
si on bouge en 6 des six faut pas
permettre fou f6 qui gagnait le plus
long donc en jouant food et 8
on prépare une manoeuvre du roi très
certainement on va voir cette belle
manoeuvre grâce et 6 ie6 près des 2 3
des 7 3 6 2 3 6 6 3 de douvres à b5
brasser un roi à quatre rois ces deux
terminé regardez les noirs ont emmené
leurs droits ici ils veulent faire
pression de ce côté là avec le roi fou
et vii en c1
si les blancs laisse passer le roi ici
pourquoi pas peu tendu quand même tous
les six avec ce nouvel ange empêche le
roi de venir en c2 donc on a bien l'idée
de mettre laurent b3 peut-être en a 2
ans suite à un ça veut dire que le roi
sera dans le camp blanc les bleus seront
vie c'est de ce côté-là à la défense il
faudra laisser le roi blanc ici et être
noir font ça pour se libérer de l'air de
l'autre côté
voilà on voit des deux rois b trois
voilages attaque en c1 foot est roi
vas-y prend prendre cavaliers ça serait
sans doute délicat ici pour les poules
et blanc de prendre soin attention ce
type de cool quand même dangereux que
font les blancs attention aux urnes la
voyais un fou donc dans avec un fou
c'est difficile d'avoir une zone parce
qu'il a toujours un coût d'attentes mais
faire attention à toujours avoir des
coûts et parce que là on imaginer que le
fou arrive à passer un échec là le roi
est obligé de partir c'est fini tout ça
ça tombait on n'allait pas là ce projet
quatrième parce que le cas mérite en f2
pas bougé grand chose là il le roi ni de
cavaliers ça fait un peu peur alors le
clavier bouge ici quand même mais on
voyait qu'on attaque dans le vide et ce
faisant j'ai 4 n'est plus protégé les
noirs continuent à placer le roi voilà
ils viennent en a deux ça évitera
endroit bien ultérieure
si on enlève le fou par action je vous
faut deux pour attaquer est bien le roi
blanc ne pourra pas malgré que le foot à
eux de venir en b1 de toute façon dans
tous les cas même s'il blanc protège
d'abord parce que le roi l'empêchent
voilà tous ces cinq coups datant d'un
tipi que la voilà heureusement qu'on a
le fou pour attendre un peu de voir ce
qui se passe
fou au dos et j'attaque g4 donc sa force
cavaliers 2 est-ce qu'il ya moyen pour
les noirs de passer c'est pas simple ou
f3 d'attentes
voilà un peu à toi voilà je trouve pas
trop pour l'instant
comment faire mais c'est à toi de jouer
qu'est ce que tu fais est pas facile de
trouver les coûts là pas bougé le
cavalier sinon j'ai quatre tombes peut
pas bouger le roi sinon b2 tombe parce
que le fou ou alors si encore en c2
c'est vrai que maintenant que le foot
avec ses 6
les quatre foulées cette voie là attal
g4 c5 et c7 des quatre ici aussi ce
voile à coude attentes
c'est difficile de progresser les saints
voyez donc suffit pas voilà d'avoir la
paire de fou non plus voilà position un
peu statique voilà c'est ça le problème
c'est que les blancs bien placé leurs
pièces en défense cavalli protège bien
g4 qui est essentielle
on peut donc pas poussé le pur f3 tout
en ayant bloqueurs c'est délicat en plus
si le fou ici va s'échanger contre le
cavalier on a une finale de foot que
leur poser pour aider à la nulle c'est
pas sûr ceci parce qu'évidemment le
purger quatre tombes le récit on a des
pionniers c'est pas la même bien sûr
donc il faut voir comment ma tension f3
les noirs sa détente quelque chose voilà
il faut il faut y aller il faut tenter
f3 on veut menacer sans doute fou j'ai
trois prises et fou pranger 4 mais dans
ce cas là on a vraiment les foules que
leur poser le pion il ya déjà vous aurez
3 on va passer très difficile de
progresser voire même impossible en fait
donc ça fait pas forcément très plein
fouet 3,17
ces huit voix lasse et les coups
d'attentats on sent bien que c'est la
fin car senna essayé il essaye toujours
mais que faire si avec ce foot là encore
une fois j'ai c'est d'éliminer le
défenseur de jus katsers tuerie gagne un
pion mais de foot qu'on leur pose et
avec juste un pion passer ça suffit pas
ça ne suffit pas ça se démontre assez
facilement prouver c'est un bon exercice
ailleurs en fer contre l'ordinateur vous
essayer de tenir la position avec fougue
leur opposer vous allez voir que bon
c'est quasiment impossible de progresser
c'est impossible croissez 2,17 61.4
c'est mon époux d'attentes
attention là quand même attention en
échange le coût qui n'est pas de
couleurs opposées ici en mode normal ici
attention c'est le fou qui n'est pas de
couleurs opposées donc qu arsène a
réussi à essayer encore une dernière
chose mais carrière qui ne lui pose pas
de problème ils échangent
poum poum ce qui fait que l' attention
pions passé et puis ont passé mais y en
a deux qui sont envoyées ils sont
doublés c'est pas vraiment dangereux ça
y'a pas voilà il n'ya pas deux pions pas
s'il y en a qui en fait donc il ya un
pur passé contre on peut passer ça
devrait quand même faire nul sur les
rois sont en jeu son travail contrefout
du même côté bon pendant club va
chercher l'autre on peut rien faire quoi
ces deux os 6 c'est un fou c'est 8
ces deux fossiles voilà satan est ce que
les blancs peuvent pousser leurs pions
qu'est-ce qui se passerait ici
si l'élan pousser leurs pions angers 5
on peut regarder deux secondes
est ce que les noirs pourraient jouer
simplement fou et cinq échecs par
exemple ici laurent avis rien n'empêche
le pied on aller plus loin et puis c'est
tout il se passe rien parce que font les
blancs si les bords et si demain devrait
le cavalier de purger trois vallées adam
si le roi essaie d'attaquer les pions
pour pendant que le cavalier c'est de
faire d'un me lasser ses pions qui
tombait des idées noires vont faire
aussi dames de ce côté donc si on tente
des choses si vous voulez il faut pas
bouger parce qu on tente des choses
en fait on ne fait que donner des
chances de bien l'adversaire croix b 3
revient voilà ça y est bien voyez on
l'avait dit à l'heure on est venu à deux
pour l'empêcher de nuire bien mais il en
profite titien libyen donc le roi pourra
plus venir un deux trois quatre rois ces
deux rois bessèges
voilà sa part 3 d2 attention attention
quand même là si le roi arrive en f2 si
on a va pousser les pions que le roi un
peu éloigné pour calculer un peu quand
même
3 ces 6 3 des 5
à noter qu'ici le pion contrôle le
cavalier contrôle donc il ya ici une
barrière le roi noir ne peut pas passer
c'est important ça doit se voir à l'oeil
sa main sous types de finale comment les
pions et pièces empêche le roi de perse
de s'activer trop bref 5
attention qui saura de manger scène
c'est un tout petit peu pénible c'est
pour ça que le roi blanc y va il veut
pas pousser son pion et a compris car la
quine que ce serait une erreur
il faut garder cette position
m6 est là où jolie cavalière 4 attention
regardez échec et le cavalier protège la
cage des 5 es le roi donc ne peut pas
s'approcher du pion voilà donc c'est
bien vu g6 mais attention mélanger 4 et
reprise sur mes pas de problème pour moi
la très jolie couleur web 2 j'aime bien
j'aime bien ce court à f2 puisqu'en cas
maintenant regardez simplement et de fou
prend g4 et bien aimé blanc forêts sont
notables et des deux ça suffit que les
deux attaques
ici le pion ces quatre attaques aussi f3
remarquer au passage on pourrait aussi
jouer peut-être cavale et ses 5 pour
menacer de venir en bessette prendre le
pion à 5
pas mal aussi ça parce que après sur à
katia qui avait laissé cinq cavaliers en
c5 protège 17 on peut pas venir défendre
et 6e puis on saute on est un pion pas
ses sources de ce côté là pour faire
attention quand même ici donc relève de
son projet 4 donc là les blancs
joue cavalier d2 donc ils choisissent
ici que les deux alors moi je refais un
câble de six régies par un peu le fil
cariou quatre échecs en croire les six
breaks 2 donc voilà donc on n'a pas peur
de prendre père jay cap puisque c'est ce
qui se passe d'ailleurs je prends je me
fais des plans sur la comète à l'avancé
exactement les coûts en fait c'est pour
ça je ne regardais que si le coût
immédiat
bref fou pranger quatre cavaliers d2 on
voit bien qu'on récupère un voyage faut
pas avoir peur comme ça de lâcher un
petit pion si par ailleurs derrière avec
ça on permet d'en récupérer
à noter aussi qu'en f2i si le blanc
laurent blanc parle on bloque toute
initiative de pousser à daon peut pas le
déloger est temps que le cavalier mobile
on pourra pas faire dame puisque le fou
de cases blanches on pourrait faire part
à progresser en fait à droite bloque
complètement toute possibilité faut
aussi c'est là qu'on voit que lecavalier
pourrait s'avérer supérieures à ce type
de finale puisque lui peut contrôler les
deux cases dont chinois mais les noirs
sont toujours bien mais après roy f3
bref scène pour protéger quand même peu
le pion montrait bien à quatre échecs
4 un peu peut sembler curieux puisque on
met le pion s'attaquer par le fou mais
le cavalier veille et puisqu'on va se
venger sur c4 puis sur à sinclair faut
faire attention
fodé seck on repousse le roi 2 est là
simplement large et 4 où l'attendra tout
simplement est ce que les blancs peuvent
progresser c'est pas facile si on va
acheter en bouche le trou avec
lecavalier
il faut trouver des cadeaux si en plus
ça de toute façon même si on bat la la
si on bat l'attention parce que voilà on
peut avec les noirs allaient prendre le
pion à 4 donc le cavalier reste en d2
bon et qu'elle est vraiment là attention
alors qu'est ce qui se passe ici sur
qu'est ce qui se passe sur su repousser
6,6 il faut regarder un petit peu quand
même c'est la dernière un petit peu
astuces attention attention faire
attention aux progrès simplement des
taux loin des 2 et noir ne jamais
prendre à 4 sinon ils perdent non
seulement ces 4 mai à 5
et là par contre attention deux pions
liés c'est le blanc qu'on avantages du
cloud donc qu'elle ait fait simplement
roger 5 se trompe pas on met en garde le
contrôle finalement ne voyez comme ses
pions c4 a été finalement menaçant toute
la partie pour les noirs alors qu'ils
s'étaient un pion doublé au début et qui
tient la position c'est lui qui tient
l'opposition depuis depuis longtemps
déjà
quel est des deux qui créent et qui a
permis au noir de prendre cet avantage
mais comme on le voit insuffisant
bref c'est un de ces blocs et de manger
4 et enfin voilà rêve 2 les joueurs
signent là nul
une position on peut pas progresser très
très belle partie je trouve magnifique
finale magnifiquement joué deux quarts
sense c'est aussi cette ouverture
cariat qui n'a à rejouer un peu je
dirais à la russe la même ouverture un
peu dans le style des rues saint
d'essayer de forcer comme ça sur un
match sur une variante précises afin de
pousser l'autre à la faute sur la
variante mais il s'avère il s'avère que
ça ne marche pas sur cette variante
puisque ça fait deux fois que personne
rentre dans une vie dans une finale soit
carrément facilement nul comme on l'a vu
à la précédente soit ici qu'on le voit
bien avec même l' avantage net pour les
noirs je dirais avantage aux points là
pour qu'arsène encore on le sent dans ce
match-là pour l'instant il c'est lui qui
met la pression il exerce des gros
soucis pour vérifier car les scarlets
keane qui lui-même pour l'instant n'a
pas réussi à déborder il n'a pas réussi
à prendre l avantage
le puncheur norvégien semble en pleine
forme voilà donc je vous remercie
d'avoir suivi cette quatrième partie sur
des modèles tv j'espère que ça vous a
beaucoup plus je lis vos commentaires je
les apprécie merci merci pour vos
encouragements
donc je vous donne rendez vous à la
prochaine partie sur les modèles tv pour
la suite de ce championnat du monde
des chèques 2016 au revoir